the molecule choke it wins millionaires
and billionaires from around the world
and in recent years one nation has shown
a big appetite in five years time the
fleet of plus 40 meter yards Russian
owned as ground with 130 percent
Russians now represent 8 percent of the
superyacht market but this year the
waters may be murdered the Ukraine
conflict has seen Europe introduce
sanctions on some individuals curbing
travel and freezing assets it's
something which we see that could
influence in the future our market if
things will develop in the wrong
direction so our manufacturers worried
German shipyard lucerne has had some
disappointments we had very early
discussions with some people and they
then asked if they can postpone the
final contract which we understand
obviously and we follow the clients wish
last year he son yards sold their entire
stock 10 yachts to Russian clients we
would all like to see the situation
resolved as a mclee as possible and as
quickly as possible so we can all get on
with the business that we're supposed to
be doing despite the concerns the Heston
Sales Director still has back-to-back
meetings with potential Russian clients
none of the customers we've been
speaking to recently have withdrawn from
discussions as the result of the
situation so while there may be some
uncertainty for now here in Monaco it's
still business as usual